basically we knew that we were going to
die I mean there was really no way we
could survive it
[Music]
I think the challenge that I was most
scared about was when we were crossing
the Pacific in a hot-air balloon we lost
half our fuel about a thousand miles
into the trip and the Pacific is about
six and a half thousand miles long so
basically we knew that we were going to
die I mean there was really no way we
could survive it you know we were
traveling at about 80 miles an hour the
only way we can survive it was to
average about 180 miles an hour across
the Pacific and I was with one other
person per Lindstrand who did a lot of
my balloon trips with and we looked at
each other and and yeah I mean we
without even saying it we knew we had
little little chances the only chance we
had was to try to get right into the
core the jet stream and see if we could
get get the speed of the wind to go up
and remarkably went from 80 miles an
hour
the speedometer 90 hundred and 10 120
140 160 180 200 210 220 suddenly our
Bloom is flying at 240 miles an hour
across the Pacific and and if we can
keep that speed up we had a chance of
survival and and again remarkably dear
but we were the first across the Pacific
and yeah we did we did survive
you
[Music]